sign on a tous en tête la séquence qui
m'a fait qui nous a tous fait chavirer
la séquence dans danse avec les stars
pour appeler sa séquence autour du lit
eh bien on l'aï si vous regardez danse
avec les stars cette année ou pas oui ah
ouais je ça vous plaît ça me plaît je
comprends encore plus pourquoi le
programme étant suivis et et pourquoi ça
s'appelait tant que très belle saison et
dick tiff où elle aurait alors on va
revoir cette séquence pour le bonheur
main sur de nos téléspectateurs et pour
le bonheur de gilles verdez voilà qui en
coulisses vous allez voir dans un
instant en shy'm je sais que vous
attendez ce moment c'est parti à
regarder
quoi
il
alors
charest sur la tête de ma mère
genre une mode animaux ranaldi d'hôpital
cannes et moi ça alors on va faire qui
sera la meilleure chose que de regarder
ces oiseaux lilas sur la tête d'un chat
faire la belle chorégraphie autour de
soly attention séquence triste avec tout
sur des visites tout de suite voici la
première sharif est la première chose
c'est bertrand chamerois sebha
merci de recommencer
mauroy merci c'était le tonnerre et pas
mal au mal
s il est pendant la série elena le gall
le gars fait très très peur quand même
sur le lit d'hôpital avec sa tête et son
corps quand même là on est dans vol
au-dessus d'un nid de coucou aïe aïe aïe
aïe aérienne bertone et on n'avait pas
vu la deuxième
la deuxième c'est shine verdez
si ça tu fus qu'un peu toi merci merci
merci
mais un fusil vers des gens lui
aujourd'hui et je crois que jean luc et
génie au début je pensais qu'il fallait
un père et police fap et des
vétérinaires ses clients il faut il a
failli stocks très bas l'eau plus parce
que le lie à rouler on est d'accord
alors franchement là il avait il se
péter le nez et c'est qu'il est un
curseur ou parce que ce jour soit c'est
en fait c'était vrai allez on va
accueillir tout de suite notre troisième
shy'm à ya eu les lacs et reebok et qui
est très propre
il faudrait peut-être faire le livre se
permettre thierry c'est pas le pire dans
la chorégraphie et le lys était celui du
sens aussi le troisième alors lui
franchement je l'attends gazole on l'a
jamais vu faire des trucs comme ça y'a
que sur des bidons tous marre au poste
idées comme ça et julie à trouver
moi
il fait ce qu'on lui fait passer pour
ben moi j'ai battu l'envoyer je crois
que la meilleure scène c'est julien way
à nos téléspectateurs
oui tu pouvais voir été fait par des
professionnels ne le fait pas chez vous
je suis là je gagne à fond d'annoncé non
c'est bon c'est bon c'est gênant ça nous
fait penser je ne sais j'ai déjà vécu je
croisais la voyons qu'il a déjà vécu là
ça c'est sûr que ça va le changer de
mettre noachovitch 12 août qu'est-ce qui
fait pas pour nous note julien courbet
on peut l'applaudir japonais
tu as corps était là